so explain to me what's going on when
you move your arms
the sum total of the angle momentum
uh the angle momentum of
you okay no i'm not okay you have no
idea
today we're going to talk about angular
momentum any spinning object such as the
earth here which is rotating has an
angular momentum which has the symbol l
the of momentum is a vector quantity so
brady put an arrow over the top just to
indicate that it's a pointy thing the
angle momentum is pointing up in this
case from the south pole to the north
pole as it's rotating that way round
that's the direction of it the magnitude
depends upon the mass of the earth
times the radius of the earth squared
and there's a numerical factor which i
can't remember but it's a first year
calculation to do and you don't want to
know about the numbers but it's
proportional to that
and
it keeps on going unless there's some
force of friction on the side which i'm
providing with this blue tac by getting
it either to slow down like that or to
speed up and it's this
sideways force whoops
moved the earth move for me yeah see if
i can get it to work
i know i have to take it out and put it
back in again
can you do this george
before
all right let's start again
you'll fill me aren't you no
you're lying
until
so this is any rotating object and we're
going to illustrate it further by
looking at bicycle wheels one of the
reasons you don't fall off a bike or
i hope you don't fall off a bike is when
you're pedaling it
there is anger momentum associated with
the rotation of the wheels
we've got the key george
this is a bicycle wheel which before we
start we'll leave it stationary and see
what happens if i dangle it from a
string
i'll dangle it from this side i think
and of course it wants to fall out of it
but if i keep it like that the string
will hold it vertically it doesn't want
to remain like that at all
but if my beautiful lady assistant
george would like to
get that spinning
i'm not allowed to do dangerous work
all right george
thank you okay
so now i'm going to hold it
by putting this
string over here and dangling it down
and you see if i left it without the
spinning
it would want to stay
in the horizontal plane but now actually
the angle momentum wants to keep in the
same direction
unfortunately it tires tip over when it
tries to tip over it goes around a
circle
but it doesn't want to fall off this is
a very very stable arrangement well if
you're riding a bike
and the bike is going along and you
suddenly tip over
it doesn't really want to carry on in
the same direction it would prefer to
revert back to the vertical and you
design the bike wheels and the front
forks in such a way that it it leans you
back into the right direction so the
angle momentum tries to remain constant
going down the axis and tipping it over
well it doesn't like being budged away
from the direction it's moving so the
faster you go the more stable you are if
you're trying to do it standing still
completely stationary it is quite
difficult to balance on a bicycle and
completely impossible on a mono cycle
angle momentum is
conserved unless there's some friction
which will get things to slow down
so
if you get an atom in a particular state
it will stay in that state with a
particular value of angular momentum or
if you have a bicycle wheel that's going
round and there's no friction it will
carry on rotating forever or if the
earth spins round if there's no friction
the earth will keep spinning around
forever there is going to be a little
bit of friction because of the air
molecules rubbing against the earth or
the water rubbing against the the shores
and there will be some friction that
tries to slow it down but that apart it
will keep going and keep going well at
least for my lifetime which is all that
matters as far as i'm concerned i'm
sitting on a chair which he just rotates
very easily so i am actually a spinning
object at the moment and i don't want to
be a spinning object i want to make sure
that my angle momentum is zero and then
george is going to spin the thing up so
much that there's going to be a huge
amount of momentum so i start again and
there's angle momentum this way but i'm
not going to worry about there's no
angle momentum about this axis
vertically but if i switch this way this
is now rotating around and i have to go
the other way in order to keep the total
angle momentum constant and now i've
turned it back and i'm going back the
other way and i can keep that is fun
keep turning it over
and the total angle momentum remains
fixed and turning it over again and i
come backwards
so the sum total of my angle momentum
about this axis and the wheel's angle
momentum is the same apart from the fact
that there's a bit of friction a bit of
friction will slow the wheel down but
even when i'm at this stage i can turn
it the other way and the angle momentum
about the vertical axis is constant all
right all right so what are you doing
now now i'm going to
show you that the angular momentum also
depends
on how i distribute my mass now my
masses distribute in my self-like body
uniformly
i wish
and i'm going to illustrate the effect
of distributing mass by carrying a
kilogram weight on either end so george
would you like to rotate me around with
my arms out and
it's the moment of inertia it depends on
the distribution of mass
and how far it is away from the center
of axis
ah
and if i bring these masses in the angle
of velocity will increase dramatically
and i'm going to be sick
and then oh can you spin me oh dear
what is a professor when he spins
oh
the sum total of the angle momentum
so what happened there was after i was
sick um
start again
and what happened there was that as i
put these weights out just like an ice
skater who's spinning putting her arms
out
you rotate around and with the arms out
you have a lot of angle momentum
associated with these masses far from
your body which is part of your moment
of inertia now as you bring your arms in
as i brought these masses in
so your angular momentum remains
constant the moment of inertia goes down
because you've brought them in closer
and you speed up and you really get
giddy i don't know how those ice dancers
do it because they somehow lean their
head back and don't get giddy and and
they go around like that forever but you
know oh dear
i'm not really feeling myself